[Music]
[Music]
we've all been there you're on call in
charge of an entire production system
such as if peak traffic on the East
Coast which are on the other side of war
sleeping like a baby
you have no idea what's about to hit you
in my nightmares here's what I see the
pager goes off in something like this
you wipe the sleep in your eyes
grab a computer to investigate you still
have asleep and have no idea
what's really going on traffic jams are
forming all around the area users have
no idea where to go to avoid traffic
time to start debugging millions of
people are counting on you you open the
CPU graph for this server group as you
know this is CPU this is so you know the
service is CPU bound and it all looks
normal
all the scaling did its thing it was set
to keep the CPU under 45 percent and
that's exactly what it did the number of
instances doubled when the CPU started
to climb so why isn't the service
working feel a cold sweat forming is not
going to end well all instances in this
server group are currently completely
failing their health checks you connect
to a sample server and you see that it's
at 100% CPU why take a day stuck and
nothing's come to you can't see anything
if you restart the application look at
the logs just to see the startup
sequence see if you can find anything
but it all looks fine the dependencies
are loading the application starts fine
but yes once it started CPU jumps right
back to 100% a bad feeling
creeps up your spine at this point you
connect to another server and this one
completely idle how come you look around
and you can't even find application
running there at all what's going on
here what's the CPU graph from earlier
lying to me
CPU graph usually don't lie you check it
again and you realize it's an average
CPU graph how did I miss that so it
appears that some servers are running at
100% CPU burning up practically
thrashing not doing anything while
others are completely idle so you ask
yourself am i in over my head your heart
tries to pound its way out of its chest
every chest when you realize you have no
idea how to fix this then while looking
at the logs suddenly instance gets
terminated thrown out and you can't
debug it anymore in the UI you see even
more instances committing suicide
interest rates which were just started a
few minutes ago this doesn't make any
sense
system scaled up only to kill itself in
the loop
come on is it time to admit failure wake
up some more people from the team to
help you're supposed to know what you're
doing here you're professional to think
for a minute what on earth could be
causing this and nothing
come to mind okay okay so you pick up
the phone about to call for help you're
about to hit Send and then it hits you
that's Auto healing Auto healing is like
the immune system it's supposed to
replace unhealthy instances but in this
case it's all of them so it's doing much
more harm than good you dig through the
console to try to find out where to shut
down other healings wasting a few more
precious minutes you find another server
which is still up an idle why is the
application not running there keep
combing the logs trying to find
everywhere well you're looking
everywhere you can until you finally
find this apparently each server upon
startup connects to a configuration
server to download this configuration
without it it's pretty much useless so
this configuration server apparently
fell over and managed to do two things
at the same time one is taking down this
entire production system with it turning
a perfectly nice auto scaling group into
a set of zombie servers which are
committing suicide and to is to give you
a heart attack now that you understand
the problem you quickly fix the
configuration server scale up some more
servers and we're back to normal
[Music]
finally you double check just to make
sure and go back to bed patting yourself
on the back for saving the day you try
to sleep we find it impossible
something's still bothering you did we
really save the day we were down for 20
minutes 20 minutes with millions of
users frustrated then you realize your
job is not to be a ninja even though
it's fun sometimes your job is to
prevent these kind of failures in the
first place
you remember hearing one about the
immutable server pattern and the light
pops up in your head
if this fleet of servers was immutable
and completely self-contained all of
this would have been avoided making
eliminates the external dependencies
such as this configuration server
improving the stability of the system
not to mention faster boot times so you
wake up in the morning and run off to
work to start baking immutable images
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a an astronaut saying in space
there's no problem so bad that you can't
make it worse and it speaks to dealing
with the level of complexity and
pressure like in this story where you
can quickly feel like you are in sinking
sand the complexity of rolling out
software continues to increase new
architectures micro-services
architecture the scope of deployment
multi-regional deployments global
deployments and as a response what we've
done is we've introduced measures and
processes that slow us down
and I think at this point most of us
don't think that rolling out the
production hourly daily weekly monthly
quarterly is a good idea let alone
feasible and meanwhile what's on the
table is early and often feedback that
we're doing the right things frequent
opportunities to pivot and change
direction when we need to and from some
side effects of doing more frequent
rollouts such as the scope of change is
smaller because you're doing more
frequently so there is inherently less
risk so there's a lot of talk out there
about continuous delivery but we need to
talk about really what's important in
terms of first principles behind
continuous delivery not just the tooling
and Google's been doing this a long time
we have made our share of mistakes we
have lessons learned and based on that
we have a set of opinions we want to go
to share those lessons learned with you
along with some tangible examples
continuous delivery can't just be about
better orchestration it's one of the
things that's not it so my hope
throughout this talk all of you guys
came in attended because you care about
this my hope is to get us a community
thinking about and talking about and
implementing the right first principles
as they go on takeoff continuous
delivery my name is Steven Kim I'm an
engineering manager out of New York City
and this is Tom kleiner he's a systems
operations engineer for ways if you
didn't guess and we're here to talk to
you about continuous delivery and a tool
called spinnaker which one walk you
through spinnaker is an open source
multi-cloud continuous delivery platform
developed at Netflix Google joined the
project some three years ago and along
with other members of the community like
hands-on we open sourced in October
November of 2015 Google and Netflix we
found a kindred spirit in one another
and the way we go and approach the kinds
of problems that Tom described earlier
what I want to do today is I want to
share with you four first principles and
for each of these walk through how they
manifest at ways to ground them a bit
and give you some tangible examples and
then at the end hopefully we'll have
enough time we'll walk through a simple
demo
okay the first first of all is immutable
infrastructure that's all talked about
it means that once you deploy something
you don't change it when there's change
you reel it up from the coast up or the
container up and then you tear down the
old one all together how many of you
guys have not heard of immutable servers
or remedial infrastructures okay great
great so it's widely out there why do we
want to do this why is the middle
infrastructure important we want our
process of building and testing and
deploying and validating to be as
deterministic as possible we know that
across environments there is a lack of
hermeticity where the configuration
shifts address and as you go and deploy
and promote move from environment to
environment that things changed and just
because you know that it worked in one
environment whether it be your developer
local workstation or in a non production
staging or stress environment there's
still a lot out there through which
things can go wrong from that promotion
to the last production stage we want to
go to minimize changes flipping in as we
go to move up the runway and here's the
way it works in practice you bake every
time you have a change you bake an image
using hacker or for those of you who are
using configuration management software
like puppet and chefs you run that as
much as you can and then you bake it
into an image
so in gtp it's Google GZ images and then
at the Floyd time you go and dole those
out into GC instances okay so for those
of us who those of you who are from the
container world it seems really familiar
you're right because it's the same thing
you take your application binaries
you're dependent on time stacks you find
them in a docker file package of your
configuration file to a doctor image
using GC our build which we announced
earlier last week or your favorite
service is just talk or how Burk way and
you go and create docker container
images and then you go and instantiate
then using for example could maybe
scheduler into pods or whatnot
so there's some other benefits as well
to the mutable infrastructure if you
remember one of the early messages about
the public cloud was elasticity right an
elasticity has to do with long long time
window elasticity that you don't have to
go and buy upfront and then eat the cost
but it also had to do with
responsiveness to demand spiky traffic
for example well for those of us you
might for example be doing in San Shi 8
an instance of VM run your chef or
puppet scripts on it if that Papa script
takes 20 minutes or an hour and a half
you're not taking advantage elasticity
the demand has come and it's gone
right so there's some other side effects
like that where you have faster startup
times you can respond to demand much
quicker and traffic spikes and also it
opens up opportunities to take advantage
of things like deployment strategies
that are very particular to the cloud so
middle infrastructure is an example at
ways that Tom gave it was somewhat
rhetorical but I think you guys get the
idea the second practice is around the
use of deployment strategies there are a
lot of tools out there that people can
use to go and deploy out to
infrastructure and deploy changes to
code Jenkins is a popular one but I
started by saying it can be just about
registration and deployment strategies
is an example of this so we're talking
about deployment strategies I can
specifically take advantage of some of
what you get in the cloud so let's walk
through a couple wrong button a simple
first one it's called red black some
people also call it blue green and it's
the notion that you have a production
cluster v1 and then you have a v1 dot
one you basically create a whole new
stack running that and after it's some
validated to health checks or whatever
your criteria might be you cut over
traffic advantage here is that if
something goes wrong you can quickly
come back
there are some disadvantages as
obviously to Xing the amount of
infrastructure and resources required to
go and do this but this is a simple
example where something was wrong you
know you can go in very quickly cut back
an evolution of this is something we're
calling rolling red black and it's the
notion that you can go and define
incrementality of traffic percentage cut
overs with pelvic whe with validation
gates in between so you can say simply
say one percent five percent twenty five
fifty and a hundred percent and between
each cut over to the next percentage
mentality you can go into that
evaluation gate so it might be a
pipeline that you run which might be
very robust or it might be a simple
smoke test or a functional probe and it
also has continued stake on the
advantage of red black which is if
something ever goes wrong
rolling back is immediate another
evolution of that from there is canary
and canary is a different way to do the
validation gates in between the
percentage rollouts but it takes a
slightly different approach rather than
using functional tests or probe or smoke
tests we go and look at a set of
measurements which are much more common
regardless of what your application is
so we look at underlying metrics so
obviously things like CPU and memory
profiling but also latency response
codes error rates and you take all of
these and you create a weight by which
you go to say a certain canary score is
acceptable and that canary score also
takes into effect about an acceptable
deviation of that canary score or the
performance characteristics between your
previous version and your current
version so here's what it means test
coverage is always a cat-and-mouse game
I've covered to the 80% today every code
commit will go to lower than chess
coverage right goes in that direction so
with canary you can actually go in and
say well no matter what we're rolling
out we're going to look at a different
set of characters without a comment or
applications okay
so with that let's go Dan asked on to go
and talk about what that looks like that
ways yeah okay so ten years ago cloud
did not exist it's not as it does today
back then most companies ran their own
infrastructure and from what I've heard
in this conference some still do what's
up with that it wasn't pretty then and
it isn't now no matter how hard you
tried you could have sent API calls to
your hosting provider ten years ago
asking for five hundred servers and they
would have just dismissed us some
lunatic luckily these days it's possible
and as Steven mentioned it's part of
spinnaker so using deployment strategies
is basically baked into spinnaker and we
use that all the time it's ways right
this is how it looks like I'm sorry and
it's in a large system as meant even
mentioned it's usually impartial
impossible to test everything in advance
so we also use a canary stage it's
nonsense we like the one Netflix users
but it does the job it looks like this
basically you have a production system
running with 100% of traffic flowing to
it you then run version two in a canary
and send a tiny bit of traffic to it you
then run a canary analysis on each and
every API of that server
so for each API we test for errors
latencies and number of requests if it
all looks fine we perform a relative
compare against the production group if
it all looks fine we blow that up to a
production scale and send 50% of traffic
to the new group but still 50% of
traffic to the old one we then run the
canary analysis again this time
expecting a very similar behavior
between the two groups if there's any
significant difference we can easily
roll back by just shifting traffic back
the old group and debugging and then
destroying the old one but if everything
is fine then we just disabled the old
group and eventually destroy the third
first principle is automation
so automation promotes a consistency
right and a repeatability a consistency
is important both in success and failure
modes when things are failing you need a
consistency of facial yes basically root
cause analysis what really sucks is when
it fails in different ways every single
time right and a success
a successful consistency promotes a
maturity of process that you can go and
build on top of and so it's about
identifying and putting in mitigating
measures without losing velocity so if
you were for example to go to the right
number of tools out there that does
orchestration is a step one step to do
this and do a deploy something sales you
go oh I can't happen again I'm going to
go and write it immediately measure so I
can very quickly roll back so you write
something else and the way that this
evolved I said at the beginning of the
talk that it slows process down and it
becomes very difficult to go and improve
if you're slowing down constantly at
every time so it's difficult to improve
if you have an instrumented right it's
difficult to or yes with your less
useful to instrument if you haven't
automated and it's hard to get to a sort
of a consistency and a scale of
information that gets interesting enough
if you're not automating let me talk
about what I mean by automation so top
level pipelines go ahead and define and
execute for you your process on how you
go in and release software so for
example find an image that you validate
it looks good
go and deploy using red-black strategy
do some rudimentary spoke test we
certain one a period go to scale one
down skill Oh beautiful with deployment
strategies that we talked about before
so this is good but the automation also
has to happen in more fine granular form
under each of these steps so let me show
you for that deploy to prod red black
one stage is the spinnaker does for each
stage there are a number of steps and so
it goes and deploys in default it
shrinks the cluster it disables it scale
it down and then of each of those steps
for any one given step there are a
number of tasks that we go and perform
so this is where it gets really tricky
determining the health of things we need
to go forward you need to go back
monitoring doing necessary cache
refreshes for us to be able to our job
and then finally for any one of these
tasks there are three cloud platform
level operations that we have to go to
orchestrate so dealing with load
balancers association disassociations
target pools and removing instances and
for every single one of these my new
actions if something goes wrong to be
able to go in and auto remediated so
this is a lot that you would have to
actually go and do to say we have
velocity we have confidence what allows
you to go fast is confidence and this is
the amount of work that is done name is
in spinnaker to go ahead and promote
that confidence and you shouldn't have
to build all this yourself right you
should go in and get behind an open
source project like spinnaker which I'll
go to show you a little bit more later
and so for automation let's go and hear
what weighs us in a little more detail
all right
by the way weighs really didn't want to
go and build this stuff we're really
happy pineco existed and we've actually
been users of asgard for years back and
we seamlessly transitions into benefit
from Asgard so been great and thanks for
the Netflix guys for doing this for open
sourcing so once deployments pipelines
are in place
some interesting things can start to
happen
we basically can start using some
failsafe patterns to limit the blast
radius of changes for example at wave we
showered everything by geography
obviously this allows pipeline to limit
the blast radius of each upgrade so for
example we can upgrade for a certain
service one part of the world completely
using the red/black deployments then
move to a few more parts of the world
and eventually worldwide if you're lucky
and your look usage patterns are
predictable it's good practice to use
time restriction in deployment pipelines
this allows us to say for example that a
certain pipeline can run between 6 and
12 UTC only on between mondays and
wednesdays so this ensures that when an
upgrade occurs it affects as few users
as possible and if you're really lucky
you can try to find a sweet spot between
the off-peak hours and the office hours
then you have staff caffeinated and
ready to go to solve any issue that
might come up during this upgrade
alright the fourth and final one which I
don't think gets talked about enough is
operational integration and what
operational integration speaks to the
notion that the process of how you go to
release software needs to work hand in
hand with how your operational and that
software ok and that goes in both
directions so two simple examples one is
that when you're releasing build release
and promote so forth
that process is gathering and generating
a lot of information that is germane to
the scope where you are doing root cause
analysis or defect triaging right so for
example while you're trying to go to
figure out why something went out it's
useful to go and understand oh when we
built that software what are the key are
the commits that pertain to the change
from the last deployment to the first
here's the blast radius of a code in
config change what kind of validation
tests were run
what were the results and output from
that test all this information that is
generated at a time of doing your
deployment becomes very very useful and
important when you're doing operational
things but in the other direction as
well so you have systems that are
running and the information that is
gathered as your systems run in
production are very very useful as
you're doing your process of doing doing
deploys a simple example as we talked
about is canary analysis like an air
analysis goes and looks at how your
systems are behaving and it could do it
at point in time or statistically across
time to go and determine what is the
right validation gate to go to say the
system is behaving normally as we go to
promote from one environment to another
that makes sense and finally a release
process inevitably crosses multiple
teams I know there's a lot of good
aspirations out there about whether it's
DevOps or project methodology like agile
or whatever it might be but your process
inevitably has a lot of orchestration
and coordination that's needed across
people and teams and so what that means
is a spinnaker pipeline for example can
help you communicate and validate and
record handoffs that are necessary
between teams as you do a release
process so to give an example of that
that's a Tom thank you we all know real
life is messy and imperfect especially
when you're moving fast during a post
mortem meeting a few months back the
team recognized a certain critical micro
service which doesn't have proper
automated testing it will eventually be
written but that will take time in the
meantime we decided that we want a
person someone from QA to run a sanity
after each and every deployment to
production here's the problem deciding
to do this is one thing but actually
doing this in a repeatable manner on
every single deployed production is
easier said than done
people can simply forget tasks get
shipped around before you know it
recently bias kicks in we're back to
square one so here's how it looks like
what we
going to do here is that basically the
developer commit the code that code
starts a pipeline and spinnaker which
initiates a manual judgment stage that
manual judgment stage sends a
notification to QA asking them to
approve this upgrade because we need
resources from them to be there to run
the sanity and make a decision once they
approve and they have a button to either
approve or not approve or they can just
wait
vinegar takes over runs the full red Zac
deployments and once that's done another
another notification is sent to QA
asking to run the sanity then they have
an option to either pass the sanity and
finish the automatic deployment or
rollback and spinnaker takes care of all
of this basically going forward it just
means deleting the old version and
moving backwards just means enabling the
old version and we and destroying the
new one this has been very helpful for
us okay
so we talked about four important ideas
and I know it's a lot to take in and
we've worked hard to make this sort of
consumable and easy to adopt and create
a ramp instead of a step so let me walk
you through a simple basic demo that
takes source code and through spinnaker
applying the key principles that we
talked about deploys and promotes
something out to its production okay
Kimmy of this demo TC please all right
simple go app and really it just goes
and responds with hello world and the
background color is yellow so let's make
a change
I made a purple right yeah so I'm going
to go to initiate my release process by
pushing to the release branch in force
so what happens here is first of all
right now we'll see that what you're
looking at is a spinnaker and we see a
staging environment and a production
environment and in the staging
environment if we go to what's out there
says hello world in yellow yeah and also
in the production environment it also
says hello world in yellow so if we are
so good and you'll also notice things
like the version of the container the
tag on it matches the same thing that's
not promoted we've gone through this
once when I committed that code what I
have set up is a bill trigger this is
not in spinnaker but you can go in and
build your containers in any way docker
hub and qwave both have build triggers
and I set up a trigger in GC our build
so that when there is a push to the
release branch I go in and sugar build
and I can use a chalk or file that's
sitting in there but I want to use a
feature called GC our build steps which
allows me to go and build among other
things lean containers I just want to go
and take a quick segue to go to talk
about this a little bit the notion is
that instead of like a typical docker
file looks like something like from this
base image pulling this source code and
build it and then identify an entry
point right and then that whole thing
happens in a container one of the
challenges there is that everything that
you needed to build it stays with you as
you go to run it so SDK dependent
packages all these things that you
really don't need is a general notion
that how you go and build in a
validation context is very different
than how you might want to build for
what you're actually run in production
right it's not really controversial and
so what you ideally
to do is do it in two steps one step I
want you to go ahead and build my binary
and then second step containerize just
that binary so that's what I've defined
over here if you guys want to look at
morale you should go to the Google
container builder Google container
builder and what you'll see is I have
the bill that happened just now and if I
look at my container registry for that
service you'll notice that it's like
four megabytes right for that HelloWorld
container previously I had built it
using the standard method and it is 241
megabytes so that's like one and a half
orders of magnitude we're talking about
there and it's because the go SDK is a
matte container as well as all the
different packages like that I
downloaded okay so back to our normally
scheduled program
so in spinnaker I go and manage the
process of production in three pipelines
deployed a stage validates and then
promotes abroad okay so the first stage
first pipeline looks like this the
configuration is set such that every
time there is a change to my daugher
registry a new tag appears I want you to
pull that down and trigger this pipeline
and it really has just one stage deploy
and deploy I look at the deployment
details sends it to a stack I designated
as a staging environment it deploys a
container that trigger the pipeline and
it uses the red/black strategy and what
that means is once again equals and
brings up a new this is two kubernetes
so it's going to be a replica set and
then once it's deemed to be healthy
it'll cut over the load balancer and
disable the other one okay and you'll
notice that I said I checked on the box
that says scale down replace the server
groups to zero instances this is a non
production environment I don't have to
cut back in a hurry
let's save on the resources
okay so that's running right now and you
can see once again as I described before
for that one deploy stage deploying
shrinking the cluster under each of
those you can go and see the individual
tax tasks that are being managed to do
this okay so the next pipeline is called
validate and the validate pipeline is
set to trigger when the deploy two stage
pipeline completes successfully the
first one that I just showed you and it
has two simple steps the first one is a
validate stage and this is what we call
a run job stage in spinnaker and it
basically allows you to point to an
arbitrary container and run it and
whatever the exit status for that
container is it'll go to proceed
accordingly and for me it's actually
just a simple it's a curl command it
goes and curl the end point that I
specified which is my staging end point
and if it comes back with a 200 it'll
say it's a it's a zero exit code it will
continue and then finally at that point
I have a manual judgment stage which
notifies somebody and then that person
has to go and say yep everything looks
good yes or no okay this is by the way
I'll take a moment real quick continuous
delivery and continuous deployment so
continuous deployment is all the way to
production automated and continuous
delivery typically entail somebody being
a gate to go to say yet this was ready
to go finally let me see if that came
through lemme oh here we go
so at this point you'll notice that my
staging environment would be purple busy
purple is purple
and you notice that the Container tags
are also different right so it looks
good I'm going to I'm going to go to
promote it so when I hit continue my
third and final pipeline will run and
here's what that looks like the
configuration as you might imagine a set
but this pipeline will trigger when the
validate pipeline completes successfully
can you do a couple of things first I
find the image from the staging
environment I know it was good I tested
it I want to use that instead of
rebuilding or locating that image
otherwise and so I can give it
coordinates to go to say from the
staging environment take the image from
the newest group that's out there and
give me that image I take that image and
I deploy a canary and for that
deployment I go and specify the canary
environment I don't use any strategies
because I don't want to manipulate
traffic in any way right I just want to
bring something up and put it into the
same load balancer and I put up one
instance okay so now we have the old
production as is at full capacity and
then we have one instance of the new
version in a canary environment both
taking traffic from the same load
balancer so what will happen at this
point is your users are visiting and
one-ninth
how many over that percentage you comes
down to will get the new version and
you'll start gathering data and the idea
to start gathering so let me show you
around how well that's going if that
looks good after the canary is done I
want you to go it and notify somebody
they'll look at the canary data and
approve and then at that point they'll
do a red-black deployment to production
so looks good let's go ahead and cut
over the production environment using
red black to the new version which will
disable the old one what you'll notice
or all point to that I deployed prod I
use red black but I don't scale down the
replaced server groups so they're
sitting there not taking traffic
because red-black disabled them but it's
sitting there why because if something
goes wrong we want to be able to cut
over cutbacks very very quickly and we
have ad hoc operations where you can
click button and then it goes and rolls
back a sense traffic out for the old one
again instantly and then we tear down
the canary and once again we use
locators that say the newest server
group in the canary environment go ahead
and tear that down so it destroy sorry
destroy server group stage and at this
point
Canaries dead we have just old frog new
prod old Pradas disabled right let's not
be too hasty let's force a two-hour wait
because that worse all it's doing is
playing down resources right then
destroy that old prod so at this point
if I look at where my pipelines are my
canary went through it's waiting for
manual judgment if I go back to my
clusters view here's my production and
here's my canary so I don't know what to
really expect because I never done this
with more than me everybody pull out
your phone can we go back to the slides
please oh that is the production end
point so if you please navigate to md
service dot spinnaker - test net what
should happen is most of you should get
a yellow page and about one out of every
ten of you should be getting a purple
page so once you have it loaded up can
you guys raise your phones and point it
toward me oh yeah it worked oh my god oh
well you can't see it but are all going
to pop that over with our yellow
and so at this point is going to look
good
canary looks good it showed up purple
I'm gonna hit I'm going to continue and
it'll proceed on to go and destroy the
old prod is that pretty straightforward
to you guys about how that would work a
couple of things that important that
happened there it was all automated
right there was every opportunity where
we recorded every step that was taken it
followed a process that we defined and
really at the point where we get
comfortable with things that can go
wrong we can start cutting out those
manual approval stages right we can get
much smarter than this this is a demo
scenario if you have to what ways is
doing with in occur or with Netflix is
doing with spinnaker or a number of
other organizations they're doing for
more sophisticated things like for
example Waze is using spinnaker to go
into fleet upgrades of base OS based on
pipelines I couldn't handle all this for
them yep so as I mentioned we open
sourced in 2015 and we open sourced with
GTE and ec2 providers I said spinnaker
is multi cloud and a cloud foundry
provider came out there in beta at the
time and we had like red black strategy
and some basic support in 2016 we were
headed down development and we
introduced the kubernetes provider the
azure provider joined in beta Microsoft
joined OpenStack provider and really
those people from the community who are
building these things are some of them
are here in the room right now so thank
you very much we added authentication
and authorization support through OAuth
to Google Groups
getup team sam'l LDAP we added most much
more robust support for load balancers
layer three and four layer seven HTTP
internal SSL support we integrated stack
drive our logging so we're trying to
make this operationally ready for you
guys to go and take on and support for
things like auto scaling Auto healing
and also we're beginning to reach out
into other popular systems in the
ecosystem like console for doing things
like discovery and
and health readiness and in 2017 what
we're working on is we're going to be
adding an app engine provider and so
that's actually pretty much done we're
ready to start taking alpha testers so
I'll tell you how to go and reach out to
us later we're beginning on formal
support for canary strategy that's
available in the OSS realm so Google and
efforts are working very closely on this
and we expect to be at a pretty good
point at the latter half of this year
with that we're going to be introducing
rolling Webb black strategy that's also
at a very good place already another
major effort is declarative CD and you
can look at it as config as code but
it's really more than that it's more of
a holistic look at when we go in and say
here's an application so far we think
about binary and configs
but also we want to go to make that
bundle be defined as and here's how you
should deploy me and manage me upgrade
me and so forth so what that means is
that as you have spinnaker in your
organization you can have application
development teams who should be
self-sufficient define all their
artifacts code check it into a
repository and have spinnaker enact that
on their behalf spinnaker is a complex
system many micro services lots of
configuration and we recognize that this
is a high friction to adoption so in
about a month we'll be introducing
formally version releases so we will run
the full synthetic transaction
integration test for you to go and say
chiller is the combination of different
services that we have validated and work
for these providers so you can look and
know what you're getting and also we are
will be done with a spinnaker
configuration management tool that
allows you to install upgrade configure
and validate your spinnaker environment
as well there's a lot of documentation
and out there right now currently but we
think that this tool is going to be a
necessity for people to really adopt and
be successful with this and finally
we're going to be filling in operational
monitoring for the spinnaker instance
itself so that is what the deploying
your software might have performance
issues or something goes down that
somebody can be notified of that
and much more
really there's actually some really
exciting stuff that you'll hear from us
it's not little things it's pretty cool
things so spinacolada IO is our website
and we develop out the open so if you go
to the spinnaker get of organization you
can see everything that we're doing the
best way to get engaged is our slack
Channel we are a community that's 2,000
strong heavy participation people are
helping each other out it's a great
place to come get introduced into the
community ask for any level of help
people are extremely friendly and
helpful over there and also just I'll
mention as a shortcut if you want to
quickly get an instance of spinnaker out
for yourself to play around today go to
cloud.google.com slash launcher search
for spinnaker and you can in one click
get an instance of spinnaker up that you
can go and start working with they're
also a set of code labs on spinnaker
dial dial that you can go ahead and look
at that's how you can go and get started
[Music]
[Music]